hey I'm Maya so fatty i fell in love for
the first time when I was in Auschwitz I
was 16 it was a school delegation from
Israel hey I remember walking among the
barracks looking at the gas chambers and
feeling very guilty for the butterflies
in my stomach I try to concentrate in
the words of the tour guide but I
constantly was looking to see the one I
love ironically outwits was the perfect
scenery for my teenage love of course I
already knew the story of Elena France
and Rosa back then and naively I thought
I can understand them I guess that that
was the point in which I understood I
took upon myself there did sorry the
role of bringing this story to the world
he took me 15 years years to do so I had
to wait to the right moment for everyone
everyone involved to be ready to deal
with this delicate situation and for me
to be mature enough and Here I am today
there are so many people that I should
think and that should stand here with me
on this stage but most of them are in a
different continent now a first and
foremost I want to thank Mickey Marines
she's my best friend and the daughter of
Rosa she is the reason I'm here today
billion is righted the children of
Helena as well as Dogma the daughter of
France bunch all of my crew members I
have the great honor of having here my
great cinematographer ziff berkovich
Maya Clara my editor she's far away and
I want to send my deepest thanks to the
Steve dish film school that was my
second home for the last three years hey
your own blog Camille thousand Kelvin
hecka booby Rubenstein and all the
other staff members to thank that the
vid below found especially LP love that
was very involved in the making of that
film the Berenstain Rabinovich and Geshe
founds that supported the film and may
made it possible I want to thank the
academy award for this incredible vote
of trust it's a great honor to be here
today and get this important recognition
thank you very much all the crew of the
Student Academy Award Sean actor Daniel
Mary Bryan and James thank you for
unforgettable week my mother and father
Miriam and Avram sarfati from whom I
will literally Oh everything in my life
the whole so fatty family as well as the
self family and last in my list and most
important nilsa my producer my husband
my partner thank you for doing that
journey with me without you none of it
would have happened thank you